zeig mir dein gehirn und ich sage dir ob
du trans bist also letztens gab es hier
dieses video frauen und männer haben
verschiedene gehirne davor alles klar
okay okay hier wir reden darüber
und viele von euch haben gefragt was ist
eigentlich mit dem gehirn von trans
personen freunde der sonne es ist wieder
soweit durch ein tee macht es euch
gemütlich wir reden jetzt über die
biologie hinter transgender
[Musik]
die wissenschaft geht davon aus dass
transgender und biologie eng miteinander
verknüpft sind
denn unsere gedanken sind nicht einfach
materie los sondern sie sind grund
biologisch alles psychologische ist auch
gleichzeitig biologisch es sind alles
zelluläre molekulare prozesse an die
interessante frage ist doch jetzt werde
ich als trans person geboren und wenn ja
wie
das zu erforschen ist ziemlich
anspruchsvoll deswegen fangen wir
erstmal an mit den problemen also mit
den sachen die wir nicht wissen und
gehen dann zu den sachen die wir wissen
problem nummer eins
trans studien sind klein für große
datenmengen und gute statistik gibt es
nun einmal nicht so viele trans personen
dann weiß ich genau wie viele aber
schätzungsweise sind es unter ein
prozent der bevölkerung und diese zahl
wird eigentlich noch kleiner wenn man
alle personen aus schließt mit einer
hormonbehandlung um eben zu untersuchen
welche faktoren von geburt an eine rolle
spielt denn hormone beeinflussen uns auf
im erwachsenenalter und auch unser
gehirn problem nummer zwei
das gehirn ist plastisch glastisch
bedeutet das gehirn entwickelt sich ein
leben lang weiter je nachdem was wir
erleben was wir lernen was wir hormone
auf uns einwirken
das heißt wenn man einen unterschied
feststellen solche im durchschnitt
zwischen cis personen und trans personen
im gehirn dann kann man jetzt noch nicht
sagen
sind diese unterschied im laufe des
lebens entstanden oder wollten sie damit
geboren
problem nummer drei länder und
geschlechter nicht dasselbe gender ist
nicht das biologische körperliche
geschlecht sondern die soziale
geschlechterrolle oder das
geschlechterbild also etwas kulturelles
und
gesellschaftliches aber es ist auch
etwas psychologisches und damit auch
etwas neurologisches und etwas
körperliches mein gehirn beeinflusst
jetzt wie ich denn da sehe aber auch
gender als soziales konstrukt
beeinflusst auch wiederum einige
hirnstruktur weil es ja plastisch ist
das macht es total schwer gender
biologisch isoliert zu betrachten weil
diese gesellschaftlichen aspekte da
immer mit reinspielt und die sich
gegenseitig beeinflusst problem nummer
vier korrelation ist nicht gleich
kausalität dazu gibt es auch noch ein
ganzes video korrelation kann ich messen
aber die geben wir noch keine ursachen
beispiel so ein quatsch beispiel sagen
wir trans frauen haben sternförmige
gehirn ok dann kann ich nicht sagen ob
ein stern förmiges gehirn zu transit
entität führt oder ob trank sein mein
gehirn sternförmig macht oder weil es
gleichzeitig und es irgendwie ganz
komplex miteinander verwoben ich kann
nur sagen sternförmige gehirn und trans
sein geht miteinander einher ich weiß
aber nicht ob das eine das andere
verursacht oder andersrum oder es ist
noch viel komplizierter
vielleicht spielt eigentlich die
spezielle sternform eine rolle also ihr
wisst was ich meine
ok genug probleme was kann man jetzt den
sagen oder vermuten über die ursachen
von transgender so etwas auf eine
hypothese also eine wissenschaftliche
vermutung ist transgender ist wenn meine
geschlechtsorgane nicht zu den
geschlechtsmerkmalen meines gehirns
passen dann kann man denkt man hat das
gehirn gestellt merkmale aber dann
erinnern wir uns an das video frauen und
männer haben verschiedene gehirne bei
unserem gehirn die tatsächlich ein so
genannter die mortis muss vor abgeleitet
vom griechischen die more fonds was zwei
gestaltet heißt der biologie heißt die
morris muss das innerhalb derselben art
zwei verschiedene erscheinungsformen
auftreten hier reden wir von einem
sexualmord ismus oder geschlecht die
morris muss das sind biologische
unterschiede zwischen männern und frauen
die sich nicht auf die geschlechtsorgane
beziehen das kann sachen sein wie
bartwuchs oder durchschnittliche
körpergröße und auch im gehirn gibt es
gewisse merkmale die die morf sind dann
könnte jetzt noch wieder zu sagen wenn
ihr mehr wissen wollt gibt's das andere
video dazu welche bedeutung hat jetzt
dieser dem office muss für die
transgender
forschung so es gibt eine gehirnregion
die heißt bst und diese bsc gehirnregion
ist bei männern deutlich größer und sie
spielt eine rolle beim sexualverhalten
in einer studie hat man jetzt diese bst
cee region bei verschiedenen
versuchsgruppen gemessen erstinstanz
frauen also biologische männer die sich
als frauen identifizieren
zweitens trans männer also biologische
frauen die sich als männer
identifizieren und schiedsmänner und
frauen die sich mit ihrem biologischen
geschlecht auch identifizieren das
ergebnis obwohl transfer biologisch
körperlich männer sind war ihre bcc
hirnregion kleiner also so wie es frauen
und auch andersrum die trans männer und
eine relativ große bcc region ähnlich
wie die cis männer in einer anderen
studie von der rwth aachen nahm an eine
art pheromon also einen duftstoff auf
den frauen normalerweise voll abfahren
männer allerdings nicht so stark
reagieren und und ihren scanner
beobachtete man das trans personen ihr
so reagieren wie das geschlecht mit dem
sie sich identifizieren das heißt trans
frauen fuhren er auf diesen duftstoff ab
transmitter nicht so sehr und es gab
tatsächlich noch mehrere studien die
verschiedenen merkmale und
gehirnaktivitäten untersucht haben die
zu dem gleichen ergebnis kamen nämlich
das gehirn von trans personen ähnelt
eher dem geschlecht mit dem sie sich
identifizieren als ihrem biologischen
geschlecht darauf muss man erst mal ein
schluck tee trinken würde ich sagen aber
bitteschön das video zu ende denn die
geschichte ist noch nicht zu ende
sie sollten bei der geschichte nie
unsere vier probleme vom anfang
vergessen ja also es handelt sich hier
um hypothesen also um vermutungen die
die wissenschaftliche und logisch
untermauert sind aber eben noch nicht
bewiesen sind was wäre jetzt eine
logische erklärung für das ganze manche
vermuten es passiert schon im mutterleib
welches biologische geschlecht wir
bekommen entscheidet sich in dem moment
wo das spermium die eizelle befruchtet
trägt es ein y chromosom wird es junge
trägt das ein x-chromosom wilson mädchen
im mutterleib entwickeln sich jetzt beim
embryo zuerst die
rechtsorgane und später dann auch schon
weibliche und männliche gehirn merkmale
also dass wir das jetzt natürlich damit
nicht fertig es ist jetzt nicht so dass
wir mit einem bestimmten gehirn geboren
werden das war's wir erinnern uns das
gehirn ist plastisch aber trotzdem geht
man davon aus der die office muss das
gehirn ist beginnt schon die mutter
leidet standard entwicklung wäre
x-chromosom weibliche
geschlechtsmerkmale weibliches gehirn
beziehungsweise xy chromosom männliche
geschlechtsmerkmale
wenn ich das gehirn und diese
entwicklung hänge nicht nur von unseren
sexual chromosomen xy ab also nicht nur
von unseren gehen denn ab irgendeinem
punkt kommen zum beispiel auch
sexualhormone ins spiel beispiel sobald
sich bei den jungs die hohen entwickeln
und diese unter anderem testosteron aus
und testosteron hat unter anderem
einfluss aufs gehirn jetzt könnte
vereinfacht gesagt folgendes basieren xy
chromosom also ähnliche gene männliche
geschlechtsmerkmale
doch dann kommt es zu irgendeiner hormon
chaos zum beispiel haben wir zu wenig
testosteron und wir kriegen weibliches
gehirn wenige male war das gehirn zeit
fertig trans identität aber mit dieser
hypothese sind nicht alle experten mit
an bord bei all den spannenden
ergebnissen darf man nicht verschweigen
das ist eine ganze handvoll studien gibt
die das ganze eben nicht sehen die eben
nicht sehen das trans frauen ein typisch
weibliches und trans männer ein typisch
männliches gehen haben also ich hab euch
am anfang die vier probleme aufgezählt
mich wundert es ehrlich gesagt nicht
dass so etwas komplexes wie gender oder
transgender sich anhand ein paar
messbarer gehirn merkmale festlegen
lässt es wäre also zu stark vereinfacht
zu sagen dass eine transfer ein
weibliches gehirn in einem männlichen
körper hat wenn überhaupt am trans
personen eine art trans gehirn dazu
passt die hypothese der
neurowissenschaftlerin im anker service
sie zeigte trans personen fotos von
ihnen selbst und von anderen personen
und schaute sich an welche
gehirnregionen dabei aktiv werden
diese gehen regionen die mit
selbstwahrnehmung und identität
körperwahrnehmung zu tun haben waren bei
trans personen anders strukturiert als
pcs person
teilweise waren die entsprechenden
gehirnregionen kleiner oder weniger
verknüpft man könnte also fast sagen und
ich vereinfache wieder stark dass die
verknüpfung zwischen selbstwahrnehmung
und körperwahrnehmung bei trans personen
schwächer ist nicht nur psychologisch
sondern tatsächlich neurologisch messbar
ist er deswegen sage ich jetzt
es ist sicher dass transgender etwas mit
biologie und mit neurologie zu tun hat
es ist jetzt aber nicht so dass ich mir
das gehirn einer trans person oder eine
person anschauen kann und dann sagen
kann ob diese trans ist das ist nicht
möglich und das wird vielleicht auch nie
möglich sein aber gender zu untersuchen
das nicht nur für die
sozialwissenschaften sondern auch für
die biologie und auch für die
neurowissenschaft ein ganz grundlegendes
forschungsgebiet der neurobiologe
antonio gouveia morgen falls diese
nachricht ich ausspreche auf jeden fall
einer der führenden experten auf diesem
gebiet findet dass es bei der suche nach
der geschlechtsidentität um sehr viel
mehr geht als nur um pronomen das
geschlecht sei einer der grundlegendsten
zentralsten punkte unserer eigenen
biologie finde ich persönlich ziemlich
einleuchtend und man muss sich einfach
nur mal vorstellen was das bedeutet
täglich über einen zentralen
grundlegenden punkt seine eine biologie
zweifeln zu müssen wenn ihr also
persönliche und gesellschaftliche
kommentare loswerden möchte die über die
wissenschaft hinaus gehen dann sehr
gerne
nur bleibt dabei bitte sachlich und
respektvoll wie es sich noch mal gehört
befreundet der sonne und für menschen
mit einem wissenschaftlichen spirits ich
komme mir manchmal vor wie eure mama ich
freue mich auf jeden fall drauf eure
kommentare zu lesen und wir sehen uns in
der endphase sonne ist ganz tolle
neuigkeiten nämlich unser video floride
fahrkarten das gehirn wurde für den fast
food science wettbewerb nominiert
es gibt ein jurypreis gibt aber auch im
publikumspreisen wenn ihr möchtet könnt
ihr uns gerne dafür unterstützen und
soll bis zum 16 oktober
könnt ihr unter diesem video kommentare
hinterlassen und das licon also es
werden alle neuen kommentaren nullen
leicht gezählt jetzt bis zum 14 oktober
dazu kommen das heißt wenn ihr das video
schon gelegt habt könnt ihr nichts wie
für uns tun kommentieren könnt ihr immer
noch und alle kommentare die eine
diskussion anstoßen zählen doppelt also
doppelt wir sehen uns nächsten
donnerstag bis dahin bleibt sicher